The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT Open Courseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi there.
Welcome.
I'm Brian Spatocco.
We're going to be going
over exam 2 from
the fall 2009 semester.
The logical place to start on
this exam is problem 1.
And what I usually do for all
the problems is discuss the
things we need to know
before we start it.
So I would recommend reviewing
these concepts before
attempting the problem.
And then attempt the
problem and then
identify your weak spots.
So here's what I personally
found to be important
information to know before
attempting the problem.
So I call it what I need, (W
I N), if you want to win.
There's four things.
The first are Miller Indices.
This is a crystallographic
notation for figuring out and
communicating planes and
directions in crystals.
So review Miller Indices
We have plane/direction
notation.
I'll explain a little bit more
what that is in a second.
Definition of planar density.
And for that matter, linear and
three-dimensional density as well.
And 4, the concept of
a crystal basis.
And this is actually the concept
that most students had
trouble with on this particular
question.
So those are the things I would
recommend you look at
before starting.
And if you haven't,
check it out now.
So let's start off with
part a of problem 1.
And so the question asks us to
draw the crystallographic
feature indicated and
label it clearly.
It doesn't actually say if
we're drawing planes or
directions and that's left to
the exam taker to identify.
So the first thing I note on
that problem, part a, is that
we're asked to draw
0, 1 bar, 2 bar.
And 1 1 1 bar.
So the first thing I notice
about these two particular
crystallographic features
is how they're actually
encapsulated.
So the first one is
in parentheses.
The next one is in
square brackets.
That actually tells us some
information about the problem.
The first part, a part one,
is 0 1 bar 2 bar.
So you actually need to know
what this implies.
Parentheses mean we're looking
at a particular plane
orientation.
Now I'm not saying a plane.
I'm saying a plane
orientation.
Which means there are infinitely
many planes in a
crystal which have
this orientation.
OK so that's distinguishing
between just
one plane and a crystal.
The second part, b, we
have square brackets.
That implies we're either
looking at a direction or a
place in a crystal.
We also have things like this,
which we're not seeing on the
exam this time but may
show up later.
We have these curly brackets
and we have
these angled brackets.
The curly brackets denote
a family of planes.
And the angled brackets denote
a family of directions.
And it's markedly different
than a particular or plane
orientation and a particular
direction.
So let's do some visuals here
to explain what we mean.
So let's start off with a 1.
Now we're asked for
0 1 bar 2 bar.
Now the bars indicate
negative signs.
So you would know that from your
Miller Indices review.
Now the way to do
this problem--
what I find is the easiest way
we reviewed in recitation--
was to not be afraid to
move your origin.
A lot of people are afraid to
move their origin around but
we have to remember in a
crystal, basically what a
crystal is, it's a unit lattice
repeated infinitely in
three dimensions.
So it's OK to move your origin
as long as you choose some
reasonable point.
So in this problem we're looking
in the back bottom
left corner.
That's our defined origin
on the paper.
But to do this problem,
I would recommend
choosing a new origin.
I chose this one.
And that's really going to
facilitate doing this problem
a lot more easily.
So let's look at what
we have to dran now.
0 1 bar 2 bar.
The 0 indicates that we're never
actually intersecting
the x-axis.
OK, so at no point
will this plane--
we know it's a plane because
the parentheses--
intersect the x-axis.
The 1 bar indicates that we are
intersecting the y-axis at
1 lattice parameter spacing.
Miller Indices are a little
tricky because they're
somewhat inverted.
1 implies you are
going the full
distance of the unit cell.
2 implies you're going
half the distance.
3 implies you are going
1/3 the distance and
so on and so forth.
So for 1, we're going to
go the distance of 1.
We're going to move
negative 1 in y.
So we're going to
move negative 1.
We're going to go to here.
That's in our y.
And when we actually make
this a little clearer.
I've chosen a new origin.
So here's my y prime.
Here's my z prime.
Here's my x prime.
So we're moving negative
1 and y.
We're going to move half,
negative 1/2 and z.
And we're also told that
this plane doesn't
intersect the x-axis.
So it must run parallel
to that asix.
Which tells me that it's going
to run along the x-axis.
We're going to get a
plane like this.
And here's our plane.
That's the answer to part a 1.
Pretty easy and most students
got this correct.
For part a 2 we're asked to draw
a direction or point to a
particular place in space.
I also moved my origin
on this problem.
And I found it easiest to
redefine my origin up here.
Which means that my new set
of axes are going to
be x prime, y prime.
I'm going to keep z because
z didn't move at all.
OK note how, when I'm drawing
these things--
we're going to draw
this one now--
that the way I choose to move
my origin generally tracks
with the negative signs that I
have. This problem I had a
negative y and negative z, I
moved in the negative y,
negative z directions.
Here I had a negative z.
So I just moved up in
the negative z.
That kind of told me how
to move my origin.
It made life a little easier.
And now it's pretty
easy from here.
Now what we're going to do is
draw 1 in the x, we'll go 1 in
the y, we'll go negative
1 in z.
We're pointing to this point.
There we go.
That's our direction.
So pretty easy.
Part a 1.
Part a 2.
So we're batting
100 right now.
And just don't be afraid
to move your origin.
That's the take-away
from this part.
The problem, of course,
gets a little harder.
That's something that we pride
ourselves on in 3.091.
If it was always this easy,
everyone would pass the class
and get 100s.
So the second part, part b, is
asking us to calculate the
density of atoms in a plane.
So this gets back to what
I was saying before.
We need to understand the
definition of a planar density.
OK, so I've sort of
defined it here.
This is rho.
Not p. rho planar.
And rho planar, I define--
to help me, maybe
it'll help you--
is the number of full atoms
in a particular plane--
in this case we're looking
at 0 0 1--
divided by some area.
Because the plane is denoted
by an area not a volume.
Don't be afraid, I mean
densities don't always have to
be mass over volume.
It can be some unit
over some specific
distance or area or volume.
So that's general density.
So we're looking at the number
of full items in a plane
divided by the area.
We're told that we're looking
at Dalium, of course named
after Salvador Dali.
And so we're also told
that we're looking
at the 0 0 1 plane.
I've drawn a bcc crystal here.
As a scientist or an engineer,
when you're given a bcc fcc,
simple cubic, the first thing
you put on that paper is the
actual crystal structure.
So I drew the Dalium up here.
Not a real element, but
a make-believe one.
And we're going to identify
our 0 0 1 plane.
This is good practice.
So there's our x, y and
our z is right here.
Our 0 0 1 plane, so we're
not intersecting x.
We're not intersecting y.
We're only intersecting z.
So here's our 0 0 1 plane.
Let me sort of bring
this down for you.
So we can look down
on it from above.
It's a square, with sides a.
And here's our atoms. So now the
question is, how many full
atoms do we have and
what's the area?
The area's obviously
a squared.
And the number of full atoms in
this area is we have four
quarters of an atom.
When you're in two-dimensional
space an atom looks like a
circle to you.
When you're in three-dimensional
space it
looks like a sphere.
So if you lived in the
two-dimensional plane, you
would see a quarter of an
atom, a quarter of an
atom, and so on.
You'd have one full atom
in this plane.
So this is sort of what
we're looking for.
And you say, oh,
well I'm done.
A lot people left it at that.
But that's not the answer
we're looking for.
We want an actual numerical
answer.
So the question now becomes,
what is a?
So we're going to digress and
find a and then we'll know
exactly the answer to
the planar density.
So a--
this is where you have to
be a little clever.
How do you find a?
The lattice parameter,
the lattice spacing.
So the best way to do this is to
think both small scale and
large scale.
So first let's think
about a unit cell.
Let me ask you, what's
the three-dimensional
density of a unit cell.
So how many atoms do we
have per unit cell?
We have our bcc.
We know in bcc there are two
atoms. We have eight corner
atoms and they're each 1/8.
We have one body atom.
So there's two atoms. So
we have 2 atoms per--
what's the volume--
well the volume is a cubed.
Now we got a cubed.
We didn't really make any
progress here, we still have
an unknown variable.
But the question is, how do
we get solved for a cubed.
So let's zoom out from
that unit cell.
Let's zoom out to a
mole of material.
OK, so a mole of material,
how many atoms are
in a mole of material?
Well by definition, it's
Avogadro's Number.
6.02 times 10 to the 23.
And then what's the volume
of a mole of material?
Well looking back at
the problem, we're
given the molar volume.
Which is something that I would
recommend you write down.
You know all the information
you're given,
see what you've got.
The volume of a mole
is the molar
volume, which we're given.
So now it's pretty easy.
We know Avogadro's, we
know molar volume.
So we can solve for a.
So not too bad.
You'll find that a is about 2.8
times 10 to the negative 8
centimeters.
You could give me 2.85, 2.79.
We're worried about
the concepts
here, not the numbers.
So don't go back and
waste a lot of time
getting the exact number.
That's our a.
And now that we've got a, we've
got our planar density.
Very easy.
I'm going to write rho plan,
just to save some time.
And that equals 1 over
this number squared.
That's one atom, by the way.
And that's all squared.
And we're going to find in the
end that our planar density is
going to be equal to 1.27
times 10 to the 15.
And the units are important.
That's atoms per centimeter,
squared.
If you don't give us the units
then we have no idea if you're
right or wrong.
So always include your
units at the end.
So hopefully that helped.
We're going to take a second
and clean off the boards.
And we're going to start
with part c.
OK we're back.
We're going to finish problem
1 now from the 2009 exam 2.
We're on part c.
So thus far in part a, we've
talked about Miller Indices,
we've talked about the plane
and direction notation with
the parentheses and
the brackets.
We've also talked about
planar density.
And I would invite you to
review those things.
Now we're going to go to part c,
which is really the concept
of the crystal basis.
And this was the part of the
problem that most students
lost points on.
So it's the thing that
I would emphasize the
most on this problem.
The problem asks us to--
and I put a sad face because
that's how people felt after
this part--
the problem asks us to
draw a particular
plane in a fcc crystal.
So we're given Magnesia, MgO.
They want us to draw that plane
and show the atoms. And
we also want you to show the
relative sizes of the atoms.
You know we have anions
and cations.
And we actually give you the
sizes of those ions, so it
shouldn't be too tricky
on that part.
But I think the best way to
start is to go over the answer
that was given that was wrong.
And then we're going to talk
about why it was wrong and how
to get the right answer.
So to start off, we want you
to draw this crystal.
The best place to start is by
actually drawing the crystal
in 3-D and then we're
going to take the
projection after that.
So people think, MgO, they see
fcc, and they say, oh that's
not so bad.
I know what fcc looks like.
Let me draw fcc.
I'm going to use for this
problem, I'm going to use this
red chalk to represent magnesium
and the blue chalk
to represent oxygen.
OK so magnesium, we're
going to have it as
a circle like this.
This is magnesium, 2 plus.
And we're going to
have the oxygen--
it's going to be slightly bigger
because it's an anion.
This is O 2 minus.
Maybe I'll color this in too.
People said, OK easy. fcc.
This is a simple problem,
easy points.
They drew what they thought
to be an fcc crystal.
So they did--
let's say they put the
Mgs on the corners.
And they said, OK now
I need my faces.
So maybe the oxygen
are the faces.
So I'm going to put in my 6 face
atoms. So here are my 1
side here, and I've got the
bottom and the top.
There's my 6 faces.
And they said, OK, easy.
I'm done.
And then they took the
projection of 0 1 1.
We also know, when you
put the axes on here
just to make it clear.
And here's our z, You know
0 1 1, we know it doesn't
intersect the x but it
intersects the y and the z at
one lattice spacing.
So x doesn't intersect.
It intersects z here,
intersects y here's.
We've got this kind of
plane going on here.
We've got something like this.
And they just drew this.
It's a little bit of 3-D
visualization But they drew
that and they got 0 points.
The reason that that is not a
correct answer is because that
is not what MgO-- it's rock salt
structure-- that's not
what it looks like.
And the reason they got it wrong
is because they didn't
understand the concept
of the basis.
So I'm going to make a
statement right now.
This is a really important
statements so I urge you to
think about it.
A crystal equals a lattice
plus a basis.
Here's the difference.
A lattice is a collection
of points.
So you have an fcc lattice, you
have a bcc lattice, you
have a simple cubic lattice.
Those are points where atoms--
I use atoms plurally,
perhaps--
can exist.
OK, a basis I like to
think of as a stamp.
A basis represents the most
fundamental pattern that you
stamp at every lattice point.
So let's draw an fcc lattice.
So I'm going to drawn
an fcc lattice on
this cube right here.
I'm going to put points.
So I'm going to make
them white.
They're just points.
I got all the corners.
They're hard to see.
But they're all the corners.
I got the faces.
Side, back, front and bottom.
You're saying to yourself,
that's like the same
thing you just drew.
It's really not.
What I drew the first time,
I put atoms in.
That's a crystal I drew.
I just a lattice right now.
This isn't a crystal,
this is a lattice.
So to actually answer the
question, we want to figure
out, we want to draw the 2-D
projection of a crystal.
So we've got to draw the
crystal eventually.
Now we're dealing with MgO.
We're told MgO is face-centered
cubic.
Which means that our basis must
have 1 Mg and 1 O atom.
So I'm going to do
that right now.
I'm going to draw what I'm going
to call to be my stamp.
You can use whatever method you
think is best. But I call
this my stamp.
I'm going to draw
it like this.
So here's an oxygen atom.
Here's a Magnesium atom.
And this little white dot
is the point that's
going to get stamped.
And here's my stamp.
And the idea is I'm going to
take the stamp, this basis--
that's what it is,
it's a basis--
and I'm going to stamp it
at every lattice point.
OK so note I have 8 corner
lattice points and I have 6
face lattice points so I'm going
to be stamping 14 times.
So I'll do the first
couple very slowly.
I'll take my stamp and
I'll stamp here.
Here is my O.
Here's my Mg.
I'll stamp over at
this corner.
Here's my O, here's my Mg.
I'll stamp in the face.
Here's the face, the
front face one.
Here's my O, here's my Mg.
So you can see what's
happening.
Let me just circle it for you.
I'll circle one of them.
Here's my stamp.
I'm going to go ahead,
I'm going to finish
drawing this in.
It's going to get a little
messy for a board.
But I hope that you can go home
and do it on some graph
paper as well.
All four corners.
The face is here.
I have a tendency to leave
off faces sometimes.
Let me make sure I've
got them all.
I already did that one.
Yep that's right.
Is that right?
No.
OK, now let me finish with the
magnesiums. The magnesiums--
it's going to be hard to
see-- exist at the
center of every edge.
So it's a little tricky but
let me explain what we're
looking at.
What you should be looking at.
We have what looks to be oxygen
in the face center
cubic arrangement.
And we have magnesium
at all the edges.
So you're thinking,
this is weird this
isn't face center cubic.
Look at the magnesium,
this doesn't
look face center cubic.
Well the thing I would challenge
you to do at home is
actually draw this unit
cell out 4 more times.
And then you will actually be
able to find face center cubic
magnesium lattic cell in
that larger unit cell.
So this is actually
the answer.
This is what a rock salt
structure looks like.
This is MgO.
You have oxygen,
looks like your
traditional face center cubic.
And you've got these magnesium
stuck on all the edges.
So now we're just going to
take our projection.
Let me use white
chalk for that.
Or rather we're going
to take our plane.
We're looking at the
0 1 1 plane.
Here's our axes again.
Remember it's always
right-handed.
We're going to do 0 1 1.
Not intersecting the
x and were going to
intersect z and y.
So we're going to come
down across the face.
We've got this.
This is pretty terrible
looking.
But this is one of the tricks
of the problem.
You have to be able to visualize
these in 3-D space.
So let's slowly transcribe what
this plane here looks
like projected out
on the board.
We know that at our corners and
also at the faces of this
cube, we've got oxygen.
So here's a corner.
These are our corners.
At the faces, two faces,
we've got oxygen.
What else do we have?
We know we must be hitting
some magnesium.
Well we know that at
all the edges--
here's an edge, here's
an edge--
we've got some magnesium.
What about the center?
Well the center we do too
because we know that when we
made this stamp, the bottom face
with this oxygen, we also
stamped halfway up
a magnesium.
So there's actually a magnesium
right here.
It's there.
It's right there.
Believe me.
There's our magnesium.
And this is what we've got.
This is the answer
to the problem.
Notice how I've giving my
oxygens larger than my
magnesiums and I've got
it looking like this.
In fact let me let me emphasize
this even more.
The fact that you could actually
have drawn this
differently.
You could have drawn
it like this.
And it would have been exactly
the same thing.
You would have gotten
full credit.
You could have drawn this.
This is the thing that I would
recommend you try at home to
prove that this is true.
These two are equivalent
It's the same thing.
It all depends on what you
choose as your stamp point.
So I could have chosen
to put my red at
every point, my magnesium.
So this is the answer
to part c.
This part, most people
did not get correct.
Less than half the class
got this correct.
So think about a little bit.
Identify crystal as lattice
plus basis.
And then think about the full
scope of the problem.
What do we go over? when went
over Miller Indices, went over
designation and crystallographic
notation, so
plane and direction notation.
We went over the definition
of planar density.
Think about what linear density
means, think about
what three-dimensional
density means.
Don't be afraid to
not use mass.
And the last thing we just
covered was the crystal basis.
So review those and hopefully
you did well.
Thanks.